На час карантину першокласниця одеської школи Злата Оніка
гостює у бабусі на Волині, але жодного дня дівчинка не пропустила шкільні уроки.
Аби зустрітися з вчителькою та однокласниками,
їй достатньо мати смартфон, підключений до інтернету.
Попри хвилювання на початку дистанційного навчання,
зараз мама Злати Аліна вже бачить його позитивні результати.
Насправді нічим вони не відрізняються, ці уроки, від звичайних уроків.
Вчитель дуже цікаво все пояснює і треба сказати, можливо,
це сучасні діти такі, що вони вміють уловити цю інформацію.
Вона через інтернет, через відео може зрозуміти, як розв’язувати різні типи задач
або можна писати математичні диктанти, можна навчитися читати і так далі.
Однак можливість повноцінно навчатися в умовах карантину мають далеко не всі учні.
За результатами опитування батьків, проведеного освітнім омбудсменом
у перший місяць карантину, близько 13% школярів не мають постійного
доступу до інтернету, приблизно стільки ж вчиться лише частково,
кожен сотий не отримує знань взагалі.
Якщо говорити саме про український досвід, то
він, власне, підтвердив тенденцію, що в Україні
є дуже різні школи і дуже різна якість освіти. Більше того,
він показав, що навіть в одній школі є дуже різні вчителі.
Одні дуже радісно сприйняли цю можливість і досить швидко
перелаштувалися на новий формат роботи, а інші так і не змогли переступити себе.
Саме для тих школярів, хто не має гаджетів, інтернету або чия школа не забезпечила
ефективну віддалену роботу на час карантину, вже більше місяця
працює дистанційна школа онлайн.
Уроки для неї на базі приватної школи готують вчителі з різних закладів освіти,
а транслюють українські телеканали.
Таким чином ми змогли додати певну інклюзивність
і долучити до уроків, ну скажімо так,
соціально незахищених дітей.
Є надія, що те, що ми зараз знімаємо, воно стане отаким
допоміжним інструментом не лише під час карантину,
коли діти опановують дистанційну освіту, а що це стане
першим поштовхом до якогось більшого продукту.
Формат телеуроків абсолютно новий для України.
Щойно проект розпочався, викладачі й організатори зазнали неабиякої критики
через помилки в ефірі. Тепер кожен урок проходить
дворівневу перевірку експертів, а деякі відеоролики збирають тисячі переглядів в Ютубі.
Однак експертка з освіти Іванна Коберник наголошує:
дистанційна школа онлайн не може бути основним джерелом якісних знань.
Перегляд телеуроків - це пасивне споживання інформації,
це все одно, що просто слухати вчителя, мовчки сидячи на уроці.
Це не є ефективна технологія навчання.
Дитина вчиться, коли вона має зворотній зв’язок від вчителя,
коли вона сама щось робить, коли вона ставить запитання,
отримує на них відповіді,
коли вона веде певну когнітивну роботу...
Звісно, що телеуроки цього не дають.
Батьківські форуми рясніють скаргами на дистанційне навчання.
Тут сотні дописів про надмірну кількість домашніх завдань,
відсутність викладання та зворотного зв’язку від педагогів.
Така ситуація спонукає батьків шукати альтернативу школі на час карантину.
Донька Тетяни Даценко почала дистанційно займатися з репетитором математикою.
Із часом до занять доєдналося кілька її друзів.
Це робило урок динамічнішими для дітей і дешевшим для батьків,
адже вартість учні ділили між собою.
Тепер Тетяна організувала платформу для індивідуальних і групових занять онлайн.
Сплачуючи фіксовану місячну плату, на уроках одночасно
збирається декілька дітей, часто - з різних регіонів.
Мені здається, що онлайн-освіта дає набагато більше можливостей насправді.
Там немає проблеми з крутими онлайн-дошками,
немає проблем із тим, щоб проводити квізи як самостійні.
Це набагато швидше, це дуже прискорює перевірку,
не треба вчителям сидіти над зошитами.
Набагато-набагато все швидше, ефективніше.
Поруч із онлайн-освітою карантин може сприяти популярності
альтернативних навчальних закладів.
Цей столичний освітній простір для підлітків і батьків позиціонує себе як демократична школа.
Просторі кімнати тут мало нагадують традиційні класи,
тут не вчать за чітко визначеною навчальною програмою.
Замість неї - карта знань і запити від самих учнів.
Ми працюємо над тим, щоб люди захотіли вчитися
і навчилися глибоко розуміти і досліджувати цей світ.
Це основна ідея. І тому карта знань, про яку ми говоримо, -
це все, що має вміти, розуміти, знати кожна освічена людина,
яка хоче не просто якось жити,
а якось впливати на світ і відповідно, щоб цей вплив на світ був осмислений.
Під час карантину у освітньому просторі "Майбутні" триває онлайн-навчання,
однак акцент роблять не стільки на знаннях, як на підтримці учнів та їхніх батьків,
надаючи можливість провести цей час максимально наповнено.
Водночас учителі, батьки та експерти, які спостерігали чи брали безпосередню участь
у навчальному процеси в умовах пандемії, спільні в своїй позиції:
живе спілкування залишається ключовим для якісних знань і соціалізації школярів.
Особливо, це стосується учнів молодшої школи.
Аліна Оніка, щодня спостерігаючи за донькою-першокласницею,
бачить, як їй нелегко без звичного шкільного середовища.
Якщо говорити про онлайн-спілкування й живе спілкування,
то діткам не вистачає безпосередньо живої комунікації між учнями.
Я маю на увазі комунікації безпосередньо між учнями.
У неї багато дуже подруг в класі. І так само, вони маленькі ще.
Це їхня перша вчителька. Вони люблять обнімашки, люблять з учителем погратися.
І хоча в цьому навчальному році учні вже не повернуться до навчання у шкільних стінах,
досвід дистанційного освіти може бути використаний
під час карантинів через сезонні ГРВІ чи повторне
припинення навчання через коронавірус.
Так само у відкритому доступі в інтернеті залишаться уроки,
які нині транслюються по телебаченню.
Їх, до речі, активно використовують ще й школярі з тимчасово непідконтрольних
чи окупованих територій, яким бракувало якісного освітнього контенту українською.